okay so
let's play
in oh sullivan
oh sullivan gamma time
i'm playing against kevin gambit
who might try and counter gambit somehow
okay
with my first o'sullivan since i
released the video
a few days ago
oh no my pawn
i am curious like how many people
watching actually saw that video
i did put a lot a lot of effort into
like sharing the traps and the
the key variations
so the point is there's a few traps like
few cool traps after bishop takes b5 but
it's also a way just to get a more
dynamic position
because white has the center we get the
diagonal
there's some like g5 g4 ideas at some
point
where it's usually black continues with
uh c5 very soon
oh c4 okay so i didn't cover this move
in the video
but white's basically declining the
gambit
um it's an interesting move too if i
take and then play this
there's queen b3
and then i think i just lose a piece
i mean i have to take
i might play just like e6 or c6
wow
oh so white's gaming ah white's not
taking back the pawn
oh
so do i
i'm just calculating wait
c5 takes takes takes queen a5 here takes
and then b4
takes
takes c2 queen d2
there's also bishop a6
so just hold on to the pawn
we'll play bishop basics
usually the bishop wants to be on b7
but the point is i'm trying to slow
white down
yeah knight b6 was another playable move
but uh
i want to keep the knight in the center
and
develop another piece
okay so queen c2 so now i could play
knight
here
uh knight b4 is another resource
also thinking of like c5 and then knight
here
and knight before
let's go for knight b4
just gaining time on the queen i might
even have knight e3
which could be cool
like queen c3 knight t3 takes takes and
i just have a pawn on d3 supported by
the bishop
in white's territory
there's a question what if white plays
2a4
then you just want to control the center
and laugh at white's
half crab
oh blue robo dragon said more opening
lesson videos on youtube please
yeah i could do more
there's a lot that i probably want to
cover
a lot of various gambits and
just random openings i play
oh okay so now my rook's attacked
um if i play this there's on passant
colon raging goose duck
oh
[Music]
thanks for that surname user
okay so i have c6 or knight c6 if knight
c6 is d5
so i'm leaning towards c6
but then a3
a395
i would really like to make this work
somehow
i'll play c6
realizing this game might not count for
the tournament
if we get down to a time scramble
it's a very reasonable move
i really want to play this but i'm not
being provoked yet
the question is how to develop the rest
of the pieces too
i would really like to
remove the queen
i mean i think i'll just play g6 it
feels a little bit slow but g6 bishop g7
casting and then eventually f5
and then in the event of taking
i could consider taking with pawn and
get rookie eight
thank you papa axe gear gifting to jimmy
hop
it was a cool position though
like i played the o'sullivan gambit to
try and gather the pawn but now i'm the
one up a pawn and white's trying to get
counter play
a3 is a playable move i could
immediately play this
i'm more inclined to play this though
and then eventually knight d3
so i pin
the drawback of queen a5 is i leave e7
less defended so if i castle
i would have to worry about bishop e7
on the plus side the queen is now
aligned with the bishop
i might end up playing h6 like h6 g5
kwit a5 also enables knight d5
d5 is well supported
hey it's taki what's up toggy
you're joining a little bit late
half hour or no not half hour
uh
oh wow we were at one one one one one
one hour and 11 minutes into the stream
but in the grand scheme of things you're
joining me let's go i just woke up after
three hours
let's go
yeah you're actually joining very early
in the stream
first hour down about 11 more to go
hope you had some nice sleep
oh very brief sleep
oh yeah this pond is just chilling in
white's territory
we'll see how long it can survive
there's a really funny line
so there's a line uh
knight e1
d5
on passant
and then i have a cool move
oh it's not allowing me
hey hey hey
if i just take
this queen takes
i am only half the party of the toggy is
imrose and let's go
oh
but you still contribute to the party
thanks josh
takes takes takes takes
and c7 is actually an issue
maybe i'll play
i can kind of just ignore things and
play h6
i play this move too
looks logical
things might get really really spicy
d6 could be coming
axo typo yeah shout out to axel taivo
wait is there a gambit called kevin
gambit
or maybe that's just what my opponent is
playing this game
wow good job when is your next otb
tournament
oh i'm not actually sure
it could be sooner than
i think
now i can castle
because the pawn's defended
with that move
what is this position let's take
yeah i was more scared of d6 right away
before king b1
[Music]
wow
thank you danger cats i hope you know
that the studies you make are super
helpful i poured over the o'sullivan
chess study
i just realized i almost have quadruple
pawns
i just need one more capture
i think i'll take here
let's take here
i have to keep my pawns intact
i'll take here
oh but my pawn might get undoubled or
untripled
but there's there's uh
i was about to say don pymond there's
pawn diamond potential
oh it's fun structure i'm down the
exchange
also if i want this game to count for
the tournament i can't use more than 20
seconds
let's play d5
oh okay i have this move
f5 might be coming in the near future
look at my pawns
it's like a small dinosaur
oh i just blundered though
maybe it's okay
yeah white could have taken here
this position's so cool
i feel like i'm playing checkers
i want to play a5
use the rest of my pawns i haven't lost
a single pawn yet
but there's so much pawn tension
[Music]
uh let's trade knights
oh this position is so funny
doe
one of my pawns
i just sack let's sack for the memeing
okay
so i'm down two exchanges
but look at my pawns
i have a lot of pawns twice as many
pawns as white
thinking
awesome this move maybe this move first
and my king can be the oyster on d4
yeah the thing about rooks is
they only move sideways and up and down
oh the key wants to come to c3 though
that's okay
my knight wants to maneuver then my king
wants to be the oyster
okay i've oysterized my king
oyster or the pearl i don't know
this game's not counting for the
tournament
it's such a cool position though
or will account for the tournament
no it won't
okay so i'm setting up for the next game
wow
i'm gonna achieve the diamond
oh it's so beautiful
okay that was a very temporary diamond
i'm threatening made in one
it was a cool pond mate
it's hard to stop too
if rook here
it depends where the rook moves
i kind of want to play this move next
look at this move
oh no my bishop
okay so if rook takes bishop there is c2
mate
and in this line
where's my mate
it is my 25th birthday
thank you for the 12 hours stream as a
president
that was so thoughtful of you eric
smile yeah just for you
oh this position is so fun
like why is this move
i don't want to play with my food too
much i mean this
this gets the job done
okay
the pawns are getting promotions
okay a very timely resignation too
okay that was a fun game
if anything that will go on youtube
with sullivan gambit leads to
some type of masterpiece
so the funny line
i kind of wanted to try and achieve
was this position if 91
uh d5
as one of these ideas again where
when ultrasound happens your old video
on the scandinavian defense with four
dots before and that will finally got me
past 1
300.
oh nice to hear future matthew
yeah so if on poisson happens here
both pawns leave the the fifth rank in
one move and then i win the bishop with
check and defending mate
so
that didn't quite happen
and then here yeah white can play d6
top engine move
and i think i would have been in some
trouble
because if e6 and my pawns are
ridiculous
and if i take that's even worse because
i probably end up getting mated somehow
okay fun game though
thanks to my opponent
uh yeah this c4 was actually kind of
tricky because the bishop takes c4
and bishop b7 at some point you're gonna
invent your own tricky and aggressive
gambit and you're gonna have to figure
out what to call it